اذا سفينتان صينيتان سوف تصلان بعد قليل
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي الاولى الان هي
باتجاه الرصيف المعد
لوقوفها والاخرى تليها ايضا
تحملان هاتين السفينتين رعايه من الصين
وكذلك من باكستان
272 من الجنسيه الصينيه وكذلك
شخصا ايضا من الجنسيه الباكستانيه سادع
الصوره ايضا تتجول ولكن سوف ينضم معي في
البدايه العقيد مسفر القريني وهو متحدث
الرسمي في حرس الحدود مرحبا بك العقيد
مسفر بينما الصوره ايضا توضح ملامح
السفينه الصينيه التي سوف تقف عند الرصيف
رقم عشره او رقم تسعه تحديدا دعنا نتحدث
اليوم عن المهام التي تقوم بها في مثل هذه
الحالات او يقوم بها الحرس الحدود في في
هذه الحالات طبعا باشر حرس الحدود مهام من
ضمن الاعمال والمهام المنوطه لوزاره
الداخليه والقطاعاتها المشاركه في تقديم
المساعده في عمليات الاجلاء
المواطنين او الرعايه الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه من السودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي والتي سنحت لهم حكومه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
عمليات الاجلاء الى حتى وصولهم الى جده
ومن ثم المغادره الى بلادهم بكل امن
وسلامه يقوم حرس حدود بالعديد من المهام
من ضمنها حفظ الامن والسلامه داخل الميناء
وكذلك
المنطقه المحيطه به وكذلك تنظيم عمليه
دخول
العاملين وللمينا وكذلك
الرعايه والمواطنين الذين من خلال عمليات
الاجلاء المستمره كما يقوم حدود بتنظيم
الحافلات والمركبات داخل الميناء لتحقيق
الامن والسلامه للجميع طبعا سخر حرس حدود
جميع الامكانيات الماديه والبشريه
والتقنيه لخدمه هؤلاء القادمين الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبمتابعه مباشره
من ساعات مدير عام حرس وحدود اللواء محمد
عبدالله الشهري ياتي هذا العمل
بالتكامل مع الاجهزه الحكوميه المعنيه
بتقديم وتيسير وتسهيل الاجراءات
للقادمين للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
حتى الوصولهم الى بلدانهم بكل امن وسلام
اكيد مسفر بينما ايضا الان السفينه تاخذ
المنحنى وعكس في عمليه اتجاه حتى تكون في
موقفها السليم يعني هناك اعداد كبيره
اليوم نتحدث عن اكثر من 3000 شخص من
جنسيات من اكثر من 90 جنسيه وصلت السعوديه
وايضا دخول السفن الى داخل المياه
الاقليميه التي تقوم حرس حدود بحمايتها
ايضا دخولها الى بوابه المينا هنا امور
كثيره وهي من المهام المناطه الى حرس
الحدود كيف تتعاملون مع ذلك
طبعا يقوم حرس الحدود بهذه المهام الموكله
له في حمايه هذه السفن في المياه
الاقليميه وكذلك في اثناء دخولها الميناء
حتى وصولها الى الرصيف حتى انتقال الركاب
الى
القادمين عن طريق هذه السفن الى صالات
المغادره الى بلدانهم باذن الله ان شاء
الله هل تلقيتهم اي بلاغ تهديدات لبعض
السفن التجاريه تحديدا
اثناء
سيرها او اثناء عبورها من عرض البحر
الاحمر باتجاه السعوديه من بورد سودان الى
جده لا لم يردنا في حرس الحدود عن اي
تهديدات شكرا لك اذا كان هذا حديث العقيد
مسفر الجريني وهو المتحدث باسم حرس الحدود
السعودي والذي تحدث عن المهام التي تقوم
بها حرس الحدود وكذلك مشاركه حرس حدود مع
الجهات الحكوميه الاخرى طبعا نحن نتحدث
تحديدا هنا في ميناء جده الاسلامي وهو احد
المواقع التي تحدثنا بها سابقا والذي
يستقبل سفن تجاريه وكذلك عسكريه مثل هذه
السفن التي الان نشاهدها مثل هذه السفينه
هي سفينه
السفينه الصينيه التي تحمل على متنها 72
شخص من الصين وكذلك
223 من الجنسيه الباكستانيه
وجميعهم قدموا من السودان ويشان هو هي اسم
هذه السفينه الاولى الصينيه سوف تتبعها
ايضا سفينه اخرى صينيه وكذلك الجسر البحري
ما زال متواصرا حيث يتوقع ان تصل ايضا
سفينتين
بحريتين اليوم واحده تجاريه والاخرى ايضا
سفينه عسكريه هنديه خلال الساعات القادمه
بينما ايضا نستقبل هذه السفينه هناك في
الجهه الاخرى وتحديدا في الجسر الجوي
وايضا تحديدا في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه في مدينه جده تستعد ايضا طائرات
عسكريه اجنبيه
الوصولها ودخولها الجوي السعودي وهي تنقل
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه قد تصل خلال
الساعات القادمه وكذلك ايضا هناك طائره
طائرتين
تايلانديتين سوف تغادران من السعوديه الى
تايلاند بعد ان قامت بعمليات اجلال
لمواطنيها ووصولهم الى جده وتم انهاء
اجراءاتهم وبعد ذلك سوف يغادرون الى
تايلاند بسلام وامان عمليات الاجلاء
متواصله لم تتوقف نتحدث بحرا ونتحدث جوا
وكذلك الخدمات اللوجستيه المقدمه سواء في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه من الجهه الاخرى
او كذلك ايضا في ميناء جده الاسلامي هنا
وايضا هناك في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه نحن نتحدث تحديدا عن الجسم البحري
فبرج المراقبه هنا او مركز عمليات برج
المراقبه في ميناء جده الاسلامي
بتسهيل دخول اكثر من عشرين سفينه عسكريه
وتجاريه خلال اسبوع تحمل رعايه من جنسيات
مختلفه
تجاوزوا الثلاثه الاف شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه سهلوا مهمه عبورهم ووقوفهم على
الارصفه المحدده في ميناء جده الاسلامي
تحديدا الذي نقف فيه هناك اثنين وستين
رصيف مساحه تتجاوز 12 كيلو متر مربع يعني
ان هذا هذه الارصفه او هذا الميناء هو
متاح لكافه السفن التي تنقل هؤلاء الرعايه
وكما تحدث ايضا يوم عندما اجرينا عده
لقاءات وكذلك تقارير من داخل مركز عمليات
برج المراقبه والذي اكدوا ان المهمه
الاولويه دائما او المهمه الاولى
والاولويه
للسفن العسكريه او التجاريه التي تنقل
الرعايه والقادمه من عمليه تسهيل مهماتهم
طبعا في غضون هذه اللحظات يتوقع ان تظل
هذه السفينه حتى تقوم بالوقوف على الرصيف
قرابه العشر دقائق نحن نتحدث عن سفينه يجب
ان يكون لها اتزان وتوازن معين وايضا لو
نلتقط الصوره نشاهد على سطح الان
السفينه هذا المصور يقوم على سطح السفينه
نشاهد هناك جلوس الرعايه ووقوف الرعايه
على ظهر السفينه ايضا نشاهد سلك عسكري
وكذلك حمايه عسكريه في داخل هذه السفينه
ووقوف ايضا
البحريه او جنود البحريه الصينيه على ظهر
السفينه استعدادا لاعطاء التوجيهات
الاخيره وكذلك
الوقوف على هذا الرصيف ويتمكنون من النزول
طبعا هناك رصيف رقم تسعه وهو المحدد لهذه
السفينه تحديدا التي سوف تقف بالقرب من
بالقرب منا سوف تقف هذه السفينه وكذلك
ايضا نشاهد الاعلام التي دائما ما تحملها
اي السفينه عسكريه وهي تعطي دلالات
واشارات كبيره ولكن عند دخولها الى
الميناء فهي تقوم برفع علم البلاد التي
تدخلها ونشاهد علم السعوديه وايضا العلم
التي تحمل هذه السفينه او البلد
منشا هذه السفينه وهي الصين ونشاهدها ايضا
وهناك اعلام
واعلام اخرى وهي تعني
بحال توقف السفينه وكذلك التحيه التي
دائما تتخذ في مثل هذه البروتوكولات للسفن
نعم تفضل هاني ميناء جدا الاسلامي هو
الميناء الرئيسي الذي يخدم ويستقبل حجاج
بيت الله الحرام القادمين من كافه انحاء
العالم وكذلك هو يعد الميناء الاول حتى في
موانئ البحر الاحمر على سبيل على سبيل
الاخر بعيدا عن عمليات الاجلاء هل تتاثر
حركه المرور او الصادرات او الواردات في
الميناء بسبب كثره عمليات الاجلاء لانك
تتحدث عن عشرين سفينه خلال اسبوع فقط سواء
سفن تجاريه او سفن عسكريه هل هناك اي تاثر
داخل الميناء بهذا الامر
نعم نعم سؤال جيد نعم هذا السؤال تم طرحه
على اداره ميناء جده الاسلاميه وسالناهم
هل تاثرت العمليه التجاريه او كذلك
العمليات التي تنقل سواء من خارج من
الميناء او الى الميناء خاصه ان هناك
مواقف خاصه
للسفن الحاويات خارج هذا الميناء وكذلك
السفن التجاريه التي تنتظر اعطائها الاذن
للدخول فان الحركه لم تتغير خاصه عندما
نتحدث وكما ذكرت ان هناك اثنين
رصيفا منتشره على كافه هذا الميناء الذي
يتجاوز مساحته 12 كيلو متر مربع اي نحن
نعني ان هذا هذه او هذا الميناء تحديدا هو
يعتبر من اكبر الموانئ في السعوديه ومصنف
ايضا دوليا بانه الافضل خاصه انه يقوم
بالسلال المستمره
للسفن وكذلك ايضا استمراره في عمليه نقل
البضائع من السعوديه الى خارجها وكذلك
استقبال البضائع بانواعها
من خارج السعوديه اليها وكذلك نقلها لو
ايضا بينما تقف السفينه لو ناخذ بعض
اللقطات ونشاهد عدد الحاويات رغم ان
موضوعنا هو عن الاجلاء ولكن لا باس ان
نعطي نظره بسيطه على حجم الميناء ونشاهد
الحاويات الكبيره وعمليه والحركه السلسه
داخل هذه هذا الميناء دون ان تتاثر باي
تاثر من عمليات الاجلاء او العمليات
المعروف الحجم الكبير بالنسبه نعم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات